so let's go back to the phones let's
take one more let's go to holly
in celina kansas holly what is up how
are we doing
hi dr d great to talk to you and also
with you
i am having trouble accepting my dad's
behavior
since my mom passed away
he moved on very quickly a couple months
after she died
started dating someone new and then it
was full speed ahead
you know proposed living together
spending a lot of money on her that he
would never have spent on my mom he's
always been very
frugal and smart with money and you know
after 45 years
with my mom it's hard for me to see him
not only with someone new but also
spending so out of character and just
it seems to me like giving her all the
things that he wouldn't give to my mom
you know she would have loved to spend
all that money but he always had her on
a budget
and you know it's hard for me in so many
ways to to not only see him showering
another woman with affection but you
know also with
with things holly can i
can i tell you i know it doesn't feel
like it
but you are way way ahead of the
grieving game right now and here's why
because you are recognizing that this
that you're not okay with this
yeah it usually takes a lot of hard
conversations with folks
to get them to realize you're not trying
to protect dad you're not trying to
protect this new person you're just sad
you don't think it's fair
you love your old mom and you wanted
things to be a certain way and they're
not
and that you're the one wrestling with
this i want to tell you holly that's a
hard place to get to so high
five to you we're not gonna high five
we're gonna hug like hug from yeah
from kansas to nashville on this deal um
so thank you
tell me about your mom tell me about her
um well she
was a nurse for 40 years worked really
hard
and uh six months after she retired
uh found out she had cancer and then
spent the last two years of her life
battling that so you know i have some
guilt as far as like
she never got to enjoy her retirement
and all that money she worked really
hard
for and you know my dad
was always they always were really smart
on you know saving and planning for
their retirement
together so i guess i wish she got to
enjoy that and it's hard for me to see
someone new
enjoying the fruits of her labor yeah i
i wish there was a magic thing to say
other than that sucks
i can imagine that being hard did your
mom love your dad
oh yeah um and i just hold on did she
love him like in a
very dutiful kansas mom kind of way or
did she love him like it
recklessly she just thought he was one
of those hung the moon kind of guys
she was a soldier side by side with him
you know she put up with a lot and
and you know she stuck by him so
you know it's you know i wish that she
would have gone to enjoy
all these years where you know really
she just worked her whole life
yeah and but she got to let's i want to
back up a little
a second she got to work she did she had
to go to work every day she saved money
she
followed these plans that your dad laid
out and they did together i get that
but she also got to help people for 40
years
yeah she got to fill in a gap of when
people were hurting
when they were disconnected when they
were broken when they were just
weeping and hurting i'll add hurting
again
sitting with folks who are hurting is
one of the greatest gifts one of the
hardest jobs in the world but it's a
gift
and so your mom lived a full beautiful
life right
right yeah she did that's incredible
i want you to honor that for her right
right
so here's the the the hardest question
i'm gonna ask you
would your mom
like would you best honor your mom
by having a hard conversation with your
dad and saying i don't like the way
you're spending money i don't like this
new lady in our house
or would you best honor your mom would
she would wink at you
if you said dad you're a [ __ ]
but go get em buddy what's the best way
you could honor your mom
well i feel like being angry
i'm the only one that's hurt by it
because
he's moved on and he's happy and this
new woman is certainly happy because
she's getting all these things
so i just thought well she could be
happy because she loves the guy but
whatever
well yeah um but i guess i don't i want
to honor
my mom by not forgetting her and i feel
like he just moved on so quickly
that he didn't really honor and grieve
her i felt like he just was trying to
fill the void as quickly as possible and
that's
i guess what's making me hold on to this
is
like i feel like when i accept him with
this new person
i'm letting her go yeah
and here's the thing holly you're gonna
have to let her go
you're gonna have to let the wonderful
mother the wonderful
co-pilot with your dad this
extraordinary nurse who served the least
of these for 40 years you're gonna have
to let her go
and that doesn't mean you forget her
that doesn't mean you don't honor her
it does mean you don't punish your dad
and what what happened is he's trying to
grind out a life
is he numbing did he jump back in a
relationship trying to pretend this
never happened probably
yes probably yes yeah and you can
you can beat him up for it and i know a
lot of 60 year old men
millions of them who don't know how to
grieve
they don't know what that even looks
like they don't know what purpose
i mean they don't they don't have the
skill set for that they don't the tool
set for that
and some go on an arduous journey to
find it
and others just say you know what i'm
gonna skid out life with no more tread
left on my tires
and i earned this money i had this
picture i was going to spend it with
this woman it didn't work out
we're going to rock and roll till the
wheels fall off with somebody else
is that the most healthy way probably
not in fact no it's not
is that my place as as a
as a kid to sit down and try to piece
that
take that from my father i don't think
so um
i don't think so it's kind of like
telling a dad who's overweight
you know having yet another conversation
about well should you be eating that
at some point you know they're 60 years
old they're 70 years old they're going
to do what they're going to do what
they're going to do
and i get to choose well i'm going to
love them and just be with them
whether i'm going to fully embrace their
new chaotic life
even if that means you know that they're
going to be he's going to be divorced in
four years
and he's going to need a place to live
like you know what i mean it's just kind
of
like here maybe this is a bad analogy
but this is what i'm going to give you
you ever you have little kids uh yeah
two months old okay this may be a
terrible analogy but i'm gonna use it
anyway
it's my show right um so let's pretend
your kid's a five-year-old
and you hand them is it a girl or a boy
a boy you hand that little boy a thing
of cotton candy
and he starts eating it and he gets a
little bit on his nose and on his cheek
and you stop and you wipe it and then
you turn around to talk to somebody and
you
you turn back around and he's got cotton
candy from the top of his head to the
bottom of his chin
it's in his nose it's everywhere and
there just comes that moment when you
say
you know what dude just get it just
eat the cotton candy that doesn't mean
you're a bad mom
that doesn't mean that you don't love
your kid that doesn't mean you don't
care about us
his clothes or how he look that means in
this moment i'm
i'm just gonna i'm gonna love you and go
get him buddy right
and i'm not saying your dad's new wife
is cotton candy right but there comes a
moment when
you said it best you're only hurting
yourself you're only poisoning
what years you have left with your dad
and you might be poisoning a new
friendship with this woman
and so uh have you ever taken her out
for coffee and just said i want to get
to know you
no no okay i want to strongly
with all of my heart holly recommend you
do that because you might find that
she's not as bad as she thought you
might find she's terrible she may be the
worst
right but my guess is your dad's a
person to character
your dad knows how to pick him because
he picked one real well
and he is picking somebody to ride jet
skis with
for as long as he's got left and yeah
it is what it is i get morning and just
know that by celebrating your dad
celebrating your mom's life you're not
diminishing her
you're not forgetting her but you are
letting her go
you are letting me go yeah
well i will do my best thank you very
much remember this
growing through grief is about making
meaning and you can only grow through
grief with relationships
and so as as again calling her
this this new woman and saying hey
you're in my life
right wrong or indifferent let's get
together sitting down with your dad and
saying tell me what you love about this
new lady trying to hear it and figure it
out
it's going to be weird it's going to be
awkward it's going to be uncomfortable
but it's the best you can do there's the
old
quote in the alcoholics anonymous group
that you know holding on to resentment
holding on to this type of of hatred
is like poisoning yourself and hoping
somebody else dies right
and holly and holly you know that right
we all know that
that being angry and frustrated other
people
i just it just weighs me down right and
we also know this
this heart-wrenching
if i accept this new person that means i
gotta let my mom go
i gotta let her go she lived an
incredible life
like she said she was a soldier
i gotta let her go i'm still gonna
remember her i'm still gonna honor her
i'm still gonna love her memory but i
gotta let her
go and then we're all gonna move on with
joy in our hearts we're going to make
meaning the best we can we're never
going to forget but we're going to make
meaning moving forward
holly i love your question and more
importantly i love your heart
good for you good for you heal your
heart and go make some more
relationships